yo sloth 94 woman in that bootleg cat
show in studio right now we've got one
of the most talented dudes in the game
in this dude is finally getting his
shine got a huge record called say it
right now number one in urban yes big a
new man might do tory lanez he's in the
city tonight Tory what's going down man
yeah for sure
um you've been making music for a very
long time
been putting out mixtapes for a very
long time here you were kind of like I
feel like like three four years ago
maybe maybe not that far back but you
were kind of like I felt like you there
was like a lot of people kind of knew
you were like the next hot thing way
like amongst amongst like the industry
cats or the DJ's like you know what I'm
saying I feel like you know a long time
coming and um you know this is kind of
like my second like a second wind
yeah it's like the second one because
you know the first time I really have
but you know which is now just with the
managers with the team um so say is a
smash record and that is gonna be on
your house when you drop to two big
stages of Christmas I was our New Year's
it was one of those yeah Christmas so
you put out two mixtapes chicks tape and
then a gangsta grillz is where those
just kind of like cuz cuz we really
haven't heard anything else that's
supposed to be on the album besides say
it right yes a is the only thing solid
oh so you must be sitting on a ton muted
right yeah oh yeah I was on tour I was
on tour when I reported both of those we
like I know it sounds crazy right he was
going you know morning today night just
recording those and and we did it in the
back of the tour bus and I was just like
you know this is this year I want you
know artists to know that I'm going into
2016 strum right of course anything that
was
and then as far as um your album
obviously you are a rapper you are
amazing vocalist what I mean are you
combining the both as long as we don't
get a Tyrese black tie situation I don't
know if you remember that when he had
one this was black but I'm saying like
you started cohesively like like what
direction is it going more cuz you got a
lot of people don't know man you got far
you know it's not like it's waste one
more side than the other
is its how I always did music you know
it's just what you do you kind of yeah
it's just the music is just gonna be the
music I can't really say whether or not
you're gonna hear more melodic parts or
whether or not you're gonna feel like
there was more rapping or whatever you
want to call it going on but the music
is just gonna be different and for me I
I just focused on the fact that no
matter what I was doing it was gonna be
timeless so that's what my biggest thing
was you know and for me all of the songs
that at least that I know right now on
the album I think you know the the
differentiation I guess between the bolt
and you know the amount of the different
two are still equal right now is still a
balance for sure um when you put out the
gangster girls you called the new
Toronto mixtape is his name of the tape
yeah
now a lot of hip-hop heads would know
like guys like Kardinal Offishall yeah I
remember like I had a vinyl from some
dude now I think his name is chock lar
Claire Claire yeah now that's the old G
Toronto currently that everyone's
perception that Toronto was Drake in the
weekend mmm so what is the new Toronto
the news run it was me baby you know the
brand is like Pepsi brands like Cola man
you see everywhere you go you got an
emotional attachment to it you know for
me it's like I want people to understand
that you know this is a new face and
there's a lot of sounds that we have
heard from everybody who's come out of
Toronto you know and now it's my time to
be here but the thing that's different
about when it's my time
is just that you know the way that I
would do it in the you know that the
levels of music that I'm about to take
that I'm about to take this to his like
it had to be said that way because
people have to understand that I am the
new wave of not only Toronto just of
music you know so like with um with with
those ovo dues which breaking those guys
do you have any any relationship with
them we don't know you don't know I mean
I met I met Drake pipe twice very
briefly right you would think like you
know being that you're up next in the
city like you know I feel like Drake is
the kind of guy that has reached out you
know guys like P rain and and bet you
know bellies been wracking forever but
but yeah that's crazy what about what
about with the XO camp like able in
weekend in those guys I know I see I
meant to I met the weekend lunch but we
actually got time to actually vibe right
he's a cool dude
from from you know what I know we text
each other back and forth
that's our music that we're gonna be
working on in the future so you know
he's a cool dude I just I got a chance
to talk and get to know him more than I
got to know Drake so I don't really you
know as far as Canada right now it's
literally like fam I mean just across
the board Justin Bieber Alessia Cara the
weekend but there is II yourself it's
crazy right now kids well and it's
really getting crazy what is it about
Canada particularly Toronto because I
always I've never been to Toronto I'm
gonna try to go all-star weekend this
year but I hear that Toronto is like one
of the most eclectic diverse places you
could ever go to definitely mister it's
the melting pot of culture you know a
lot of the people who you know as
immigrants who couldn't get into America
went to Canada right um and being that
they were in Canada you know they got
with other immigrants and made babies
and all of the kids you know are so many
different so there are some bad [__]
in Toronto ever 100% we allowed to say
that on the radio we go G I mean listen
man
about two hours haiku beautiful and then
as far as I'm your upbringing like you
know a lot of people don't know that you
you kind of like you were in Atlanta for
a little bit yeah you were homeless when
you were younger you lost your mom and
you were younger yeah um but you've been
making music so long and I always feel
like when you're an independent artist
whether you rapper songwriter whatever
it's such a marathon to get on like it
really is to have your moment what was
your low point as an artist where you
almost were like man like I might have
to just like you know get a day job or
something yeah I mean I mean well I
always had a day job that was my thing
you know man so many different places I
worked at Denny's Wendy's McDonald's
subway damn I delivered phone books to
the houses place called the 84 cents
store the 84 cents yes sounds crazy 99
cents now they had me out in the cold
with a megaphone saying come out to the
84 sisters but was there a point where
you kind of like almost got to the point
where you gave up on the music thing
because they have artists you know not
for me there was a there was a point
where just nothing was happening but I
always like you know I was very
problematic in school and things like
that and I always said to myself I'm
gonna be I'm gonna be a rapper before I
even knew how to sing I was like I'm
gonna be a rapper I know it so you're a
rapper before you were singer of course
always I just thought is singing that's
crazy just happen to be good at that's
so crazy man that's so crazy
what are you doing your spare time like
what do you I mean you on the Netflix
you got any shows your binge watching
you play video games um for me I don't
know man I just like getting money you
know and I don't say that in like a
little wrapper way like I'm really like
an entrepreneur so I'm always focused on
my clothing line you know directing the
next video things that's gonna bring
revenue to me you know and I'm just I'm
all about the art like my mind doesn't
come off the art at all like you know
it's like you know how there's people
they treat it like a job and that's like
they Harvey That's not me like I'm gonna
be the biggest artist in the world so my
mind is always on the art every
single time with a day and you do a lot
of ghost writing or fair runs of
writings ridiculous it is it is it
almost like do you get more money off of
that then you get off your own stuff at
this point cuz like I'm real good
friends with Pooh Bear I just live in
Vegas with me I was just with him
yesterday who bears like my bro but like
it's very lucrative to write songs for
people is that something that has been
more to look at it for you at this
problem I mean it's kind of me a lot of
money I wouldn't say more money than my
own music's got me cuz of course I do
shows and yeah of course and you know my
music so yeah um yeah I mean it's
definitely something I do like doing and
I don't and I don't think it's a it's a
bad thing I think that you know when you
write songs even when I write with
people because I don't always write the
songs myself sometimes I write with
people and give people people so and
that's all it is it's just kind of
giving out ideas to people who may have
not had that idea 100% alright so the
album is is do we have a date yet or a
title yet song we don't have a title yet
you don't have a date yet we just we
just we just know that it's coming out
that you have a folder that you're like
okay these are these are sound it
sounded incredible right now I just
wanted to make sure that one of the when
it's all you know put together I'm gonna
name it you know I just want to make
sure that the music is it's a number one
thing I don't want to put a name there
and then I have to start theming the
music or you know I always talk to
artists about that and that's what they
say they're like if you name something
you've got you always have that in the
back your mind when you're making the
music and if it the name of the album
then you can't even make even if it's
fire it's like you got to put this road
so who were your influences as an emcee
coming out of Canada I mean obviously it
might be different in a lot of people
who were you bumping as a kid that
really influenced you as a rapper for me
um as a kid I bumped a lot of jay-z know
I listened to Kanye well my mom died I
started listening to Kanye stuff like
that because he came out he came out
around the same time my mom died Wow
and knives and of course $0.50 you know
I like thought of the rebels in the game
and the people having them you know all
the people who just lashed out and did
it their way
currently I feel like there's a
renaissance with R&B music there's guys
like yourself price and tiller hey Lonny
there's a lot of talented young R&B cats
out there oh are those are any of the
like have you worked with kailani or
Bryson tiller vibe with them I met I met
Caitlyn he she's cool people shout out
to Kyrie Irving by the way for smashing
that I see you Kyrie yeah Michaela she's
cool people and Bryson we like text like
once but now I haven't got a chance to
like work with them in the studio enough
you see have a clothing line what's the
name of the clothing line man what's
wave Nation is is you know something
that we've been working on so it's
actually a joint clothing line cuz we
rep something called one umbrella yeah
umbrella because I see that and I think
umbrella corporation from Resident Evil
could now forever umbrella is uh forever
umbrella means basically one umbrella
and we're just saying forever you know
forever umbrella is actually though like
when we put out clothes and we put out
things like that and stuff that comes
off the bread for us like music and
whatnot but one umbrella is the
corporation you know where I know you
have a relationship with meek a real
good relationship with me
lord knows you actually wrote right like
the hook and all yeah yeah so I mean he
wrote his verses I just want of course
that produced a beat would play Picasso
now obviously like people already
already associate just because they know
you're from Toronto didn't did that like
put you in a weird place with the city
like nobody like cuz when I make moves
the city move with me
you know it's I'm not one of them dudes
who they don't they don't lash against
me you know I'm I'm gonna do that kind
of give everybody hope you know cuz in a
weird way when we front of her we you
know and not to undermine anything about
anybody else but you're from you're
actually from the hood in Toronto like
you know the thing about it is is when
you're from Toronto and anybody from
anywhere in Toronto can vouch for this
right when you're from Toronto when
you're really in Toronto you're
everywhere every day right so doesn't
matter where you want where you actually
lay your head it depends on where you
were at and who you was with you feel me
but not everybody's like that now for me
I look at it from a standpoint of the
things that I've gone through being in
Toronto and how I lived in Toronto was
completely different than a lot of other
things so it's like I kind of have a
voice to the people and the kids who
feel like we come from broken situations
how can we fix it you know like and we
love as young kids growing up we watch
Drake like we like yo we just want to
rap you filming but at the same time we
always have it in the back of my mind
like we just as the Toronto kid when he
came on we believed easy do from TV and
we was always like yo that's amazing
there's someone from our city no matter
how it happened is on you feel me right
but for me when I got on is like dannis
[__] we saw every single day yeah we
saw him every day at the malls at in
every hood in different malls in every
hood selling his mixtape we saw him
downtown we saw him like everywhere we
seen him go and have beef with like this
guy and this guy and these different
crews and then still come to the party
where they were all that like we saw
that happen you know like it was it's a
thing for Toronto kids when they see me
so they look at me like the hope out of
city cuz I come from broken situations
you feel me so how much were you selling
your mixtape for I'm just curious
I was now son of a five if you
was real gullible I too got you for like
10 yeah I was selling I was I had crazy
like no I was really I was really
getting it though cuz like I had the
wavy deals like I had I was going hard
like I had the 3 for 14 Dale if you
really have bread like regardless of
fact I would have really let it go as
long as you had like over $3 its long
because you just want people to get the
music yeah cuz that's really what it was
about but at the same time you know I
want to make a little profit off of it
so you know as long as you had over $3
and he was willing to pay I had the
speech setup and everything had it all
down yeah everybody well hopefully we
get the album real soon can you tell us
who you're working with I mean I'm sure
you're in the lab with a lot of artists
who you know have you been working with
and we don't know if it's gonna make the
album but who you know who might make
the album oh um who you got in the
for-sure folder on the Mac I definitely
have artists from the Umbrella on there
you know for my crew and what are there
now we got okay so we got um first you
got me of course my brothers I have
three brothers okay
Brooks my brother's blood brothers
Brooks so skits or and Yoko Gould and
those those three are talented in their
own kind of ways is [__]
as far as in I'm sorry what those
brothers being said those is like the
four different sections so we basically
all have our own compartment in the
umbrella my section is with this girl
her name's Brittany Taylor rocky
diamonds
nice Dave only Rory and Dave all Rory is
crazy because they're actually Whaler
babies they they dad was the main
guitarist in the Wailers yeah so when
they come out it's gonna be incredibly
like awesome like reggaeton it's like
it's like it's like listening to my to
my music but at the same time with a
twist cuz they got the crazy they play
guitar they do a lot of different stuff
so I'm really excited about them as well
and um
that's just my division of the umbrella
so um for me those who I'm really
focused on you know you are obviously
ladies love you I saw in the hot 97 TV
you tell me how beautiful you were
I'll be feeling that way yo man we also
feel that way right yeah we definitely
all should craziest groupie situation
you found yourself in or like the
craziest situation with a female fan or
like someone who just you know found
your hotel room or like something like
just something that was old extra OD
that like oh yo there was just one time
right we was all it was all in them we
had this low like you ever seen those
those trucks it's like and I have the
back door the back trunk but the trunk
open up like that yeah so yo we had
packed back me a pack stuff in the back
of the trunk and we was leaving it we
was leaving one of the shows one day so
boom we packing her stuff in the trunk
right boom finish packing close the
doors close the door you feel me boom
you go to the hotel we rise to the hotel
chick is in the back chickens in the
trunk the truck yo just jump the truck
this ain't nothing we get to the hotel
open the doors she like what's up she
was brave even if she had look good it
takes a certain type of crazy [__] to
do that it takes you don't you don't
need that female to take confidence
I also you're a connoisseur of erotic
cinema as a my favorite point you know
when you watch porno like every month
and switches it's like yeah you know for
right now I'm like I like skin diamond I
don't know if he knows I like skin Dom
because I miss the dirt she should
she's the most hottest most bait with it
no they don't they do that to kids at
the birthday boy so they can feel like
they really can't get them out meanwhile
nobody I got them first I was thinking
smart I will look we should wrap up this
interview
shout out to Tory Lanez he likes Skin
Diamond any give me one more porn star
name though okay I like Christy Mack
Christy Mack yeah so you like dirty
white I'm talking you know Bonnie rotten
no I wouldn't lose her last name is -
yes she's
she's like Christie magnet knows I like
Sheila Shaw now that's what I'm feeling
this month Sheena Shaw Sheena shot -
right there she is
well yo that's what we're gonna do man
we're gonna get in to say it hopefully
we'll get album from you real soon if
not there's plenty of free so if not
know what I'm sayin
there is plenty of freezing on the
internet I mean there's a lot more on
the way as well if somebody had only
heard say it what project you want them
to go back and grab from you go listen
to lost cause lost cause go get it and
right now I'm gonna let you introduce
your single my G yo this is the most
greatest from the most hated Tory Lanez
and right now I am on wild 94 one and
this is my hit record seat
sure